treasuries yelling biting programs
to make big difference to inequality
reuters story us president joe biden's
overall proposal which includes
stepped up spending on infrastructure
child care and education will make a big
difference in
inequality u.s treasury sector secretary
janet yellen
said in remarks released on tuesday
republicans have criticized the proposed
tax increase
biden expects to use to pay for his
proposals but yellen said the effect of
a change in marginal tax rates
is much less powerful and influencing
growth in either direction
adding that her aim is to make sure
government deficits stay small and
manageable yellen also suggested
u.s interest rates may need to rise to
prevent the economy from
overheating as more of president biden's
economic investment programs
come online so do you think
the rates are about to increase
dramatically and if yes
how dramatic okay so she got her hand
slapped
that day the nasdaq dropped 400 the dow
was off by 350 points
uh somebody do you think she cares uh
she she renounced her statement that day
what i meant to say was she is the
treasury secretary she is a political
appointee she is no longer
the chair of the federal reserve
interest rates are not her purview
that is the the singular purview of jp
that's like j pal coming out and saying
the federal reserve advocates for a
strong dollar policy
the fed's not allowed to talk about the
dollar that is the sole purview of the
treasury sector she crossed
a big line it was highly highly
inappropriate what she did
and she had to come back and walk it
back because
j pal had spent the prior week telling
all of america that he wasn't even
thinking about thinking about reducing
quantitative easing reducing
the pace at which money is being printed
he was on an evangelism tour
he was for a whole week and she comes
out and just slaps that
and by the way you've got to stop
growing the fed's balance sheet before
you can even get to raising interest
rates
she skipped right over that process and
said that she saw interest rates is
rising
and the market threw up yep but it
wasn't her place
so what are you saying you're saying
rates are not going to go up anytime
soon
she was speaking with the brain of her
priorities i totally get that i got the
point what i'm saying is do you think
rates are not at all going to go federal
reserve is not going to increase
interest rates anytime soon is he going
to keep his commitment of 2023 because
that's what he said in the past before
we'll see
the pressure is building on jay powell
like you've
never read because as mentioned input
cost prices whether you're talking about
copper
or l or lumber is whatever it is crazy
30 16.
insane but shipping freight uh
costs are are higher than they've ever
been we don't have truck drivers in the
country
and now labor's more expensive because
biden's policy is paying people to not
work correct
so you and and labor 60 of any given
company's cost structure correct
is labor if jay powell is going to be
facing
companies that are they're challenged
with extraordinary inflation
and for him to hold the line through
and watch this thing blow up
and and it's it's hard to see him
holding the line unless
unless these unemployment benefits
expire which
this is what he's banking on he's
banking on september the 6th
he's banking on companies being able to
hold on long enough
to wait until unemployment benefits
expire and people are forced back into
the workforce
exactly i completely agree with that and
there's also something that we missed
that came out of the charlie and warren
show
charlie stole the headlines with all of
his
crypto and bitcoin oh i hate it it's
terrible it you know supports you
yeah the kidnappers domestic terrorists
and people that can go
you know and use the you know the the
dark side of the web and
i'm texting something to kai to share so
i'm on my phone
now then here's what they forgot and i i
don't think you missed it
um and we haven't spoken about this in
advance but i know this is not something
you would have missed
charlie and warren spoke for ten minutes
that they are already seeing inflation
that could be as high as six to seven
percent this year in america
and he said we are seeing costs pass
between our companies
where companies doing business with each
other he mentioned sugar and coke
he and now you've already brought up
transportation costs shortage
of truck drivers and uh lumber
and where we have actually you brought
up correctly we have iron ore is it a
record today there you go
so they're already saying you know uh is
nobody
paying attention here we're we're seeing
a six to seven percent inflation
this year and it and it could be it
could be even greater and we're
seeing it all right now all these houses
and everything in
south florida going up that's also
driving up rent that's also driving up
property taxes because it's all ad
valorem the property tax is a trailing
indicator
that follows the increase in housing
prices so if you have an increase in
housing prices and a lot of transactions
all those transaction houses now are
retaxed or to me they're rebased
and they're taxed tomorrow and we're
wondering why biden's already talking
about a fourth stimulus check
because without extra money all of a
sudden households are going to get
slammed
what did you think about all this in
their talk on inflation i sat back and
i'm like why are they giving charlie a
headline on
crypto and bitcoin what they just said
about inflation
yeah it was and and and you're right
charlie munger has no i i've i've
warren buffett invited me out to omaha
years ago so i i enjoyed charlie
munger's company
much more one of those little cpo
unhinged i mean he says
there you go it was a sapio moment in my
world i can see that because on the
opposite side there's nothing else going
on there but
warren buffett got warren just keep
saying ebitda
he got a ton of criticism because he
didn't talk about anything
controversial in his annual letter
people are like
this week saturday uh no no his annual
letter which came out
prior to it right right right so i think
he wanted to exert
his influence and he took that's what we
talked about and he used the microphone
to do it he did it for a reason it was a
vanilla letter
because the other shoe was live yeah i
mean and he is
but but when you when you say interest
rates are going to rise
you're taking a political shot at janet
yellen
saying 2 trillion more 4 trillion more
won't make a difference we had the tools
to fight inflation
she says it over and over and over again
we have the tools to fight inflation
not if it runs off the rails and slams
the economy into
into a recession because companies
cannot afford how do you stop the
inflation right now
what what monger and buffett were
talking about this is not government
driven
inflation this is market driven
inflation how are you going to stop it
how are you going to suddenly
invent more lumber to increase the
supply of lumber tomorrow morning bring
the cost up
by 2022 we will have the sawmills we
will have extra capacity
but next year a long time about right
now it's a long time from now
you can't you can't stop what's about to
happen economically ahead of the
midterms
it's gonna be a slaughter part of the
midterm 16 months
yeah hero
confidence is pretty high though by the
way if rates go up but you think rates
are going to go up in the next five
years to the six seven eight percent
numbers or no
well the problem is that what what
they're flirting with and what they're
flirting with
is is and and milton friedman when we
tell you this
we've had a 40-year run of falling
inflation falling interesting
40 years normally postcards 18 said
whatever cds we're paying
16 and a half percent milton friedman
would tell you that if you let the
inflation genie out of the bottle
it's really hard to get her back in and
that's when things run off the roads
especially when we're
spending money like we're drunken
sailors the government
we are drunken sailors yeah
yeah maybe they want that maybe they
actually want that if you think about it
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you